in this lecture we complete our
discussion of multiple continuous random
variables in the first half we talked
about the conditional distribution of
one random variable given the value of
another we will see that the mechanics
are essentially the same as in the
discrete case here we will actually face
some subtle issues because we will be
conditioning on an event that has zero
probability nevertheless all formulas
will still have the form that one should
expect and in particular we will see
natural versions of the total
probability and total expectation
theorem we will also define independence
of continuous random variables a concept
that has the same intuitive content as
in the discrete case that is when we
have independent random variables the
values of some of them do not cause any
revision of our beliefs about the
remaining ones then in the second half
of the lecture we will focus on the
Bayes rule this will be the
methodological foundation for when later
in this course we dive into the subject
of inference the Bayes rule allows us to
revise our beliefs about a random
variable that is replace an original
probability distribution by a
conditional one after we observe the
value of some other random variable
depending on whether the random
variables involved are discrete or
continuous we will get four different
versions of the Bayes rule they all have
the same form with small differences and
we will see how to apply them through
some examples